hot ho rejectives hello hello we have
tara erickson here today because we are
doing our halloween weekend scary scary
videos
scary his name is greg alba we're gonna
watch some nukes top five today
something about you know real ghosts
caught on tight yo are these ghosts real
we will tell you if they're real we'll
know we'll know we'll now i will debunk
i will tell you if it was 100
fake i will throw them under the bus so
quickly they will forget what their name
is
okay and we also believe in ghosts so
we'll be honest and uh also follow tara
erickson on her youtube channel right on
social media no not that not yet bring
it
[Music]
top five ghosts caught on tape
note the stories in this list are
relayed just as they were reported by
the witnesses of course it's up to you
to decide what you believe
kitchen ghost
ashy murphy a woman in cork ireland has
posted a series of videos on facebook
that she claims show a poltergeist
moving objects in her isolated
countryside jesus looks like an
earthquake yeah
[Music]
ouch
[Music]
it's really focused on that light there
oh i guess it's not an earthquake
[Music]
okay
what would this oh no no no thank you
no oh my god oh no no someone behind her
threw that
oh my god
no i don't like it
what
in the actual
okay those happen back to back to back
you plant there's some
it seemed real because the broom but i'm
like you could have some sort of thing
right because why would it happen all at
the same time what a great way to debunk
you could have a thing you could have
moves the thing you haven't you know
that there's a thing they're triggered
it's a string there's somebody back
there they're throwing the pan some guy
over here has a string he pulls down the
broom the cabinet is unexplainable that
was terrifying yeah i jumped at first i
was like this is boring and then it
would be two oh my god this is so scary
that was terrifying when this broom no
oh very real man even if it's fake i
just still was like why does it happen
back to back so quickly it's like it was
starting to get mad it was like the
person who used to live there
thinks they still live there and is
looking for the salt or something like
that yeah and they're pissed that when
they open the cabinet nothing fell out
where's all your food lady damn it woman
and they open the bread thing too no
bread
well they are famished in ireland
that's why uh the potato thing you know
i know my history that was a long time
ago that's not that i believe that
happened in 2012 okay so they're still
recognizing
we'll just get to the next one so you
stop talking basement ghost
a man hears strange noises coming from
his basement he grabs his camera to
investigate although initially he
doesn't see anything
later what after playing oh god that was
his foot find something so disturbing
that he actually calls the police a
recording of his 9-1-1 call overlays the
video footage oh [ __ ]
[Music]
i think there's somebody in my house
right now
okay
um
no terry you're leaving the frame
oh my god sorry
stay in frame while you're scared
is awesome i really i love it i like it
that looks like
okay the phone call sounded real but was
the footage real but also do the cops go
uh yeah we'll be there in 30 minutes
they don't give you a timeline cops
don't say that it could have been a fake
phone call right i think it's a fake
phone call and like you could just have
someone duck down and then pop up but
that still was very scary with the music
i mean what did he say in the phone call
i decided to go down there and see what
it was
and i think i saw
someone standing in the corner
okay all right so this guy is saying i
think i saw someone standing in the
corner well if you have this footage
where this person's clearly at points
right in front of you you wouldn't say
like you know what i heard noises and i
think i saw something cool i'm like
looking at your footage it's right in
front of you yeah like there's a there's
somebody in my house in my basement
right now they're there i have it on
camera they're right here to me they
don't line up and if you need some
direction i'm also director so you know
i could direct you how to get not
everything is an opportunity to make it
in hollywood i need you to get that
right better
get you to you know really add some
juice to it you're like oh my god
there's someone in the basement no i
swear you have to come right now
actually it's so relaxed yeah wow you
could bake it so relax you guys
hollywood i might really make it
i won't it's been 35 years trying you
have reached 53 years old please i know
please call it twice
yeah
it's time you got to follow your dreams
or face reality what is the mature thing
to do is being here facing reality
these videos with you okay it's the
closest thing to doing reaction videos
okay once in a while the uss lexington
ghost
uss lexington is an aircraft carrier
that served during world war ii it now
serves as a museum in corpus christi
texas
the ship is said to be haunted by the
ghosts of dead former crewmen workers
and visitors at the museum have
experienced many odd occurrences it just
started shaking violently i mean someone
had taken that doorknob and was just
pulling on that door making a ton of
noise i grabbed the doorknob and i
opened the door and there was no one
there i see this guy in his uniform to
go across
the passage right here right through the
wall abel moreland it was an actual news
report
and caught their own strange encounter
on tape oh no thank you
uss lexington's nickname is the blue
ghost oh
i mean they had like the actual people i
don't know it's it's
it could have been to enhance the
attraction to have customers come though
oh smart you know it's like how the
queen marry mary is haunted you know i
never hear about people actually
experiencing real haunts and then for
someone to be fortunate enough to
capture on camera it could just be
something to increase the economic state
yeah that boat is losing money and the
boat's losing money
most videos get people on that boat to
make some boat money governor got
involved said we need to get some horror
attraction here to go and it could be
the case yeah boats equal ghosts ghost
stories they blow up the boat blows up
not in a real way blowing up with money
you know what i mean your bigger better
boat really is how that's how the story
goes but getting the news people on
there does line some credence too these
people might believe it's really haunted
carlisle hotel ghost
workers at the carlisle castle hotel in
sydney australia witnessed many
unexplained things in the hotel
including breaking glasses and bar taps
that mysteriously turn themselves on
one night a strange series of events is
called on cctv
in a back room we see several expensive
bottles of wine oh no flying off the
shelf as if pushed
[Music]
meanwhile back in the front of the hotel
bar a glass suddenly flies off the
cashier's table oh they were all that
was intense
wow that was a very real responsibility
of a man who worked at the bar until his
death in the early 1990s strange
occurrences at the bar have become so
common that regular patrons have given
the ghost the name old peter
he's walking around so there are people
who believe he's talking like yeah it's
just old peter shows up around every
once in a while they say hang out throw
some glasses around just old people what
if it's the person from the first video
got so fed up that they did not have
salt or bread in the kitchen got fed up
went to the bar to grab a drink and they
didn't have any beer they didn't have
any beer started tossing tossing around
there yeah except they wasted two really
good bottles of wine those were top
shelf wines top shelf wine
just threw two of them why what a waste
show how angry he was that'll fill you
up though get get gulping you know what
i mean you got to get gulp and throw
some other stuff cardboard boxes glasses
yeah for sure people great throw them
around wine you want to drink there's
value to the wine there's value and also
good times okay sure what a stupid ghost
that's what i'm saying no brains in that
ghost kind of it reminds me a little bit
you know what i mean yeah
yeah this one right you know not in the
right here this person very clearly
that he's right here
over there he's right here baby monitor
ghost
concerned mother jade yates says that
she never believed in ghosts until she
saw this strange footage on her baby's
monitor
i never bought a crib oh it's up there
where's that
this looks like a spot oh wait there's
like a body oh that's like a baby yeah
you're right oh damn i thought there was
just a spot on the camera
or my eyes make up the body no it looks
like there's something moving
and now it went away right
yes
i don't know it could just be a camera
glitch thingy i agree
it actually looks as if something
paranormal is checking in on her baby as
it sleeps another house is a previous
owner an old man named frank oh no that
looks like a guy's face right there
that looks like a guy's face until tiny
but he's so tidy
he's a time when he become a tiny ghost
because he's been like i don't know you
shrivel up when you get old right you
sure yeah you're tiny it's very common
for elderly people to become the size of
infants yeah maybe he was tiny he was a
tiny man old frank old frank
people didn't believe in old frank never
thought he could own his own property
but one day he bought that house
worked tirelessly tiny little man mining
the coals been watching over the kids
ever since then watching over the kids
that is a little frank manuel
creepy type
i'd be like get out of here tiny frank
tiny frank it's time for you to move on
yeah they gotta sage that place sage it
the big people don't accept me up in
heaven okay what are you going to do
frank you know being an outsider can
help you be different not normal normal
is a snoozefest you know so be tiny
frank and own it you could be a fetish
that's not even like little person tiny
that's just like a baby it's a baby tiny
baby tonight
almost weird weird too weird actually so
i get it why people aren't talking to
you up there in heaven you know but hey
like i said normal boring weird tiny
weird frank almost cool even if nobody
talks to you because you look weird
because you look like a baby man
i think this
is where we end the video is it
rest in peace tiny frank yeah we'll see
you another time frank don't come visit
me though guys hit that like button for
tiny friends ring that bell
ring the bell
ring ring ring the bell you haven't
heard me do that version before
so can i go now i'm hungry
[Music]